hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions on my
Game of Thrones videos this week the big
news right now is that Kit Harington
just signed up to do a big movie this
summer with Carice van Houten with
Melisandre they're gonna make a shadow
baby together it's actually called
brimstone it starts Dakota Fanning it's
like a big Jean removi but but it'll be
a blockbuster for those that are worried
that this might mean that neither of
them will be in Game of Thrones season 6
don't worry about it
Game of Thrones is filming all the way
through the rest of the year like all
the way up to December what's likely to
happen is that they'll just be in a
little bit of Game of Thrones Season six
they have to follow up on the finale
anyway but as we learned with brands
storylines that they can put characters
to the side for a while even if they're
big characters and then bring them back
later
so bran will be back less of Jon Snow
and Melisandre and that's to say nothing
of what Jon Snow's final fate is really
the surprise of the announcement is is
that Carice van Houten is doing the
movie too so she might not be in as many
Game of Thrones episodes but on to
questions careful for spoilers if you
haven't finished season 5 yet so here we
go first question fleek asks fleek it
rhymes with reek I'm new to go so here's
my question for the Q&A
does the red God and the many-faced God
ever cross paths if so are they enemies
or allies I know there's a lot of people
that wonder if some of the gods are
really just different aspects of the
same God particularly the many-faced God
I think that for the most part the
bigger deities that we see in the Song
of Ice and Fire are different so the
many-faced guide is someone different
from the red God is different from the
great other it's a great other for those
that don't remember is the god of the
White Walkers the reason he's called
that is because sometimes the White
Walkers are called the others so
naturally being a god he'd be the
greatest other as much as george RR
martin makes up the plot as he goes
along I think he has a pretty strong
idea of how he views deities it's one of
those things that he declines to answer
in discrete terms so if you want to
believe that they're all the same God
that there's technically no way to
disprove that right now so it's still
open to interpretation and I don't think
that they're enemies or allies I think
they're just two different interests I
don't think they care about each other
like Jack and Hegar said it's all the
same to the many-faced God next question
Joey PST's could it be that there's some
working involved maybe it doesn't come
back as John but as a new actor no I
mean I think that they
would stick with Kit Harington if they
brought him back or if you worked into
an animal I know that they've recast
other actors on the show even big ones
like they've recast them out in three
times but that was more for practical
purposes like they just wanted like a
hulking monstrosity but just to talk
about working for a second the show
hasn't really explained it but all of
the stark children are wars
it's just that brand is the only one
that understands how that works I mean
he's really a green seer so that's like
an extra added level they talk about
wolf Dreams in the books those are war
dreams they're like they're seeing
through their dire roles eyes so any of
the stark children that have dire roles
that are still alive would still have
wolf Dreams next question lynnie asks do
you think that Cersei even cares or
thinks about Tyrion at the moment she
has so many other problems I think she
kind of forgot about him no I don't
think that Cersei will ever forget about
Tyrion she will find a way to blame him
for all of her problems when Robert
strong was carrying Cersei off at the
end of this season she was full of hate
for a lot of people particularly the
faith of the seven you can see it in her
eyes there she's got like her own re a
list of names that she's just gonna work
her way down let's try to guess who's at
the top of her list let's just like the
top three so we'll say Tyrion Margaery
Tyrell in the high Sparrow next question
top shelf asks who gets Dragonstone now
that house Baratheon is gone I would say
that'd be something that the crown would
decide or the small Council like Kevan
Lannister would probably pick someone
typically the next person in the line of
succession is the one that gets
appointed Prince of Dragonstone I like
the title
it's like Prince Charles being Prince of
Wales Tommen doesn't have a cousin
anymore and there aren't any Baratheon
that we know about that they could pass
it on to so it either passed to a
Baratheon cousin or they would give it
to one of the Tyrells as a way to get
them out of the way but I would just
expect Kevan Lannister as head of the
small Council to make that call next
question drew asks if John is dead is
there a POV of character at the wall to
continue this story there well you know
technically bran and davos are POV
characters but they'd have to change a
bunch of book things to make that work
it's just that those characters in the
books aren't anywhere near the wall bran
is way north with the three-eyed raven
Davos is still in the north but he's
south of the wall there is some
Melisandre POV and dancer dragons but I
don't think that she's a POV character
in winds of winter at least I'm not sure
yet they haven't confirmed like
the final POV characters yet next
question Caitlyn asks how in your
opinion will the Nights Watch react when
they meet the White Army so you're
talking about the White Walkers well
they'll all poop their pants and then
turn tail and run Alliser Thorne is a
tough son of a [ __ ] so he probably
wouldn't run but he wouldn't be able to
defend against them half of the
remaining brothers would definitely take
off the other half would try and fail to
fight them to keep them coming through
the wall just going into theorycrafting
territory what I'm really hoping to see
is that the white Walker army arrives at
the wall and the night's king finds a
way to bring the wall down it's implied
in the books that there's an enchantment
keeping them from passing through the
wall like you know otherwise a long time
ago they would have just climbed over so
they have to have a way to bring down
the enchantments in addition to bringing
down the giant wall of ice it would be
such a bummer if they just blasted
through the gate and walked through I
mean 700 foot wall of ice most powerful
magics in the world why wouldn't you try
to bring the wall down that would be
just like the biggest IMAX episode they
could do ever next question Joanne asks
heard about the season six script leaked
check it out I know what you're talking
about it's not a script it's actually an
audition that leaked there was a woman
that was auditioning for the red
priestess that they're trying to cast
for next season for the eastern
storyline one of the directors said that
they have about six episodes written
already so it could be actual dialogue
that we would see in season six the
biggest takeaway is that you know of all
the characters that people are wondering
are they alive are they dead just
excluding Jon Snow it implies that one
of those people is actually dead and
when I say excluding Jon Snow
like it's not Jon Snow related the same
thing happened last year with the tyene
sand scene with Bronn where she like
takes her clothes off and gives him the
antidote to the poison that leaked
people thought it might be fake but then
it turned up word-for-word in the
episode so this might be the same thing
so just caution for spoilers I'm not
gonna read the dialogue here but the
only real takeaway that I took from it
is like oh X character is probably
really dead next question Alexander asks
if they bring John back to life do you
think they would name him a stark I want
to see him hold on to the throne of the
Seven Kingdoms I think he's the best
character to be king
I'm sure you and a whole lot of other
people know I think that he would stick
with the same name
although the wildlings in like the other
people would just be like WTF they might
call him something else think about what
happened to Daenerys after she hatched
the dragon eggs she went from being
Daenerys Stormborn to Daenerys mother of
dragons so if they bring John back it
might be something like that I need a
name like that the only people on the
show right now that could legitimize him
would be the Lord of his house the Lord
of Winterfell current Lord the King
Tommen Baratheon or Daenerys if she took
over Westeros if she was able to take
the Iron Throne it became the true queen
it's the only thing that Tommen can do
that nobody else can is free him from
his vows to the Nights Watch Stannis
Baratheon was temporarily a king during
the war of the five kings so that's why
he said that he would do that for John
freedom of his vows and name him a stark
that's kind of a technicality really
Tommen Baratheon is the only one that
could do that next question Chris asks
do you think that the Hound would ever
come back to fight Robert strong well I
mean there are a lot of clues from the
books of which I'm not gonna explain
here just in case you haven't read the
books but I mean yes it's possible but I
think at this point it would be kind of
obvious the fan theory is called
cleganebowl most you probably know what
that is it's just you know Clegane
versus Clegane in my mind it's in like r
plus l equals j territory of fan
theories it's just like people think
that it's all but confirmed there is a
new character that they're casting for
next season that's tied up in that plot
but i don't know if they're gonna bind
him to the gravedigger for the most part
i wouldn't expect it if it does end up
happening you can pop bottles and pour
champagne all over each other
next question gustav asks if they were
to change something about robert's
rebellion in the Tarot joy flashback
what do you think it is so you're saying
like if they do at our joy flashback say
with like Sir Arthur Dayne and Lyanna
Stark how how would they do it I'll
actually present an alternate theory
that I think is kind of interesting that
the flashback if we do get Sir Arthur
Dayne won't be to the Tower of joy
it'll be Jaime's flashback and he'll be
flashing back to his encounter with a
smiling Knight he thought this really
infamous outlaw called the smiling
knight Sir Arthur Dayne was there and
ended up saving him to feed the smiling
Knight it's just another event from
history involving Sir Arthur Dayne in
another big character from the show
and most of the flashbacks on the show
tend to be for characters that are still
alive so so I mean we'll see how it goes
thank you so much for submitting
questions for the Q&A this week everyone
these are always a ton of fun to do
we're almost a Comic Con they've
announced the cast that they're bringing
kit harington is not on that list
so just fueling fan theories he hasn't
cut his hair yet unless there's like
some crazy casting news or anything like
that
my next bonus video is gonna be for the
Tyrells it's gonna be like a history of
Highgarden in the transition from the
Gardiners to the Tyrells you know back
after the war of conquest so be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll be doing a
new round of the giveaway it'll probably
post on Sunday congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner
Ross Bower you win an Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on my
channel so I can get your contact info I
don't know what the full schedule is
gonna be for Comic Con once they post
that I'll do a special video saying what
I'm gonna be doing that I'll be doing
panel videos and trailers just just like
last year so there'll be like a bunch of
extra stuff the week of Comic Con for
those asking about a meet-up though I
will be doing a meet-up
I don't know which day it's gonna be on
I'm just I'm waiting for that final
schedule to post so then I'll announce
it I don't have any merch or anything
like that to give away in future years
what I'll probably do is I'll bring like
special prints or t-shirts just like
stuff to give to people in case you guys
missed it I posted some Arkham Knight
gameplay yesterday I have my twitch
channel up and working again I just I
changed some of my audio set up so I
might be doing more twitch streaming
I'll probably try this weekend if you
don't know where the link for that is
there's one in the description all the
video game stuff I do though that'll
post to my charlie streams bonus channel
I don't really intend to post a lot of
gameplay videos to this channel or
anything like that in case you guys
haven't seen it yet I posted a casting
video for a bunch of characters that
they're looking for for season 6 you can
click here to learn all about them and
you can click here for that Arkham
Knight video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
you